[音楽]
本日は来ていただき本当にありがとう
ございますj2Cの桜井です今日は皆さん
に身振りから伝えたいことがありそのこと
を話したように輝かせていただきましたな
ので今日はこのことについてもらっさせて
いただきますでは最初に私の入学時代に
入学する前から入学した後について話させ
ていただきます私は小学校の頃一般的に
言う
積極性のある人で自分でもそれを自負して
いましたそして個々の意見を尊重して
くれる興奮に憧れその学校に入ったのです
が
積極的な生徒が多いからこそ私は自分の
意見を言うことが怖くなってしまいました
そしてその結果自分から意見を言ったり誰
かに案を出したりすることが怖くなって
しまったのです
私は小学校時代の頃自分の中で掲げていた
モットーがありましたそれは自分の意志は
貫き通すというものです
そしてこの学校に入ってからもそれを貫く
つもりでいたのですが
自分の意見を言うことが怖くなってしまっ
たことによりその意思をその元を
しゃらりき通すことっていうのが自分の中
でできなくなってしまいました
しかし自分で建てたロッドの中から
もちろんしたかったんです私もただそれが
怖くなってできなくなってでもできなく
なった自分にも嫌気がさしてという
プロレスに私はポチってしまいました皆
さんのこんな経験ありませんか自分のいけ
ないところを分かっていて変えなければ
ならないなのに変えることができない自分
にさらに飛躍が勝ってしまうこんな経験を
したのは私だけではないと思いますしかし
私の場合はそんな時に自分を変えてくれる
存在がありましたそれが押しというもの
です
その前に少しだけ私の将来の夢について
話します私は小さい頃から歌を訴えること
が大好きで歌を使う職業に就きたいと考え
ていました
友達や先生などにも褒められ自分の長所や
生きがいだと思っていたのですが大きく
なるにつれ見えてきたのは歌手になった
活躍できる人なんてほんのひと握りしかい
なくてその一握りに入るにはとてつもない
努力がある覚悟が必要だということです私
はビジネスしか考えないように人間です
そのため法律的にお金を稼げないのにそれ
に自分の努力自分が努力するということに
意味を見いだせませんでしたそして意味を
見出せないということを自分でも理解した
上で私にはこの職業は向いていないと自分
で思いその夢を諦めることにしましたとは
言っても
夢なんですそんな簡単に諦められるわけが
ありません
私も私も他社の人は見るたびに私もあんな
風になってみたいなと思ったり自分と似た
境遇の人を見たときになんで自分はこんな
に努力ができないんだろうと思うことも
ありました
しかし
友達などに私はもうその夢諦めたからなど
と話すことによって無理やりにでも胸を
諦めようとしていました
私は自分にはきっと無理という
根拠のない
嘘をずっとつけ続けてきたのです
その私を書いてくれたのが
星でした私はイレースという体験レート
さんで最初は企画系YouTubeを見て
頼りました私は自分が歌が好きなことも
あってベタ関係のことにたまることが多く
今回の手続きしないだろうと思っていまし
たしかし私が後ろにしていくうちにわかっ
てきたのはその人たちの過去にある私への
メッセージでしたそこで私は気づいたん
です最初から売れる人なんていないその時
にどこまで努力してねばることができるの
かが全てだということに
初めて結論を見つけた気がしました
私は他の人よりも現実をよく考えてしまう
傾向があったためそのような私の気持ちを
読み取ってそれに答えてくれるような
メッセージを与えてくれる存在がそのこと
に本当に驚きました私の推しはもともとは
一般人だった人です会社員だったり学生
だったりしながらそれと共に今の歌い手と
いう仕事を続けてきましたそれはつまり
プライベートの時間を削ってやってきたん
です
プライベートな告白って歌って多分知ら
ない方たくさんいると思うんですけど
そんなマイナーな世界でね
本当に家族や元気が必要だと思うんじゃ
ないですか私もそう思いました
それこそ
が自分の意識を貫き続けてきたんです私が
できなかったことをやり遂げてきたから彼
だったら大きくなれば私に自分の意思は
貫き通すということが本当に役立つという
ことを証明してくれた存在のように思い
ます
ここまでを見るとただのオタクの話はよう
になってしまいますがここからは皆さんに
私が伝えたいことというものを行っていき
ます
中学受験が終わって私はここに来て
そろそろ大学受験や進路も考える時期じゃ
なくなってきました好きなこととビジネス
で両立したいですよねただそれって難しい
ことなのは誰もわかっていると思います
好きなことだけに頼るのももちろん難しい
ことです実はいいけど私は自分の興味の
ある職業をいくつかあってそれは
好きな言葉ビジネスをどれぐらいの割合で
重視したものなのかというものを調べに
まとめたことがありますその時に分かった
のが私のような人生の道をかなり狭めて
しまう人にもたくさんの道があるという
ことですしかしそのたくさんの職業には一
つの共通点がありました
それは当たり前になりたくない自分だけの
生きていて良かったと思われる人生を送り
たいということですこの先の私の人生なん
でもちろん誰にもわからないことなんです
しかしそんな中で私はどんな形だとしても
自分が最終的に納得できる人生を送りたい
と思っていますそして私の中の納得できる
という中にはこのように皆さんに私の思っ
ていることを伝えたり
私のような悩みを築いて抱えてほしくない
そんな気持ちも思っています
私は小学校時代の自分が本当に好きでした
自分の意見を入れてそのことをみんなに
込められてそんな自分に私は今届きたい
です本当にそして戻るために何をするべき
かみんなに自分の意見を伝えたかったん
ですだから私は今回この場に立たせて
いただきました
そして先ほど私は夢を諦めちゃったという
内容の話をしましたが実は最近
将来の目標となるものができましたそれも
私の簡単すぎます私は何かのイベントが
あった時に自分は幸せ者だという指示の
ことを言うことが何回もあって私にはそれ
がとても羨ましく思えたんですだから私も
いつか今は長所も取り柄の自分の中では
思いつきませんが
いつか自分は幸せ者だと胸を張って言える
ような
存在になりたいと思っています
時々大人の方からまだ子供なんだから将来
のたくさんあるとか人生について考える
なんてまだ早いって言われることがあり
ますしかしそんなことありません
将来なんて言っても所詮数年後には大学に
入ってしまうのですからもはやから未来な
んです
私はいろんなことをする時に何を何のため
にやっているのかということを常に考える
ようにしていますそうすることで自分が
やっていることが今の目標にどのように
近づいているのかということができるから
です
そして私はこの言葉が本当に大事だと思っ
ているのでこれからも続けていきたいし皆
さんにもぜひやってみていただきたいと
思います自分の意思は貫くとこれが私の
モットーですありがとうございました